>>From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Good afternoon, my
name is Georgette Dorn.
I'm the chief of the
Hispanic Division.
It's a great pleasure to welcome
all these wonderful people.
When they planned this event,
I thought it would
snow and y paso, nevo.
So people must have come
with dog sleds or whichever
but I'm so, so happy to
welcome everybody here
to this wonderful event.
And it's my pleasure to
introduce Juan Manuel Perez,
Dr. Juan Manuel Perez, who's
our Spanish specialist,
who will introduce our wonderful
speaker, Jose Berasaluce.
Thank you.
[ Aplauso ]
>> Good morning.
I'm Juan Manuel Perez and I
work in the Hispanic Division
and it is a pleasure for me
to introduce to you a person
who I have known only
since last summer
but we have become
very good friends,
Professor Jose Berasaluce
from the University
of Cadiz in Spain.
He has been teaching for
quite a number of years,
teaching mainly postgraduate
courses.
He is also known food and wine
critic for Spanish newspapers
and magazines and he also
coordinates and manages an
in nominative [phonetic]
nonprofit web-based,
small business group
called, Catas con Artes,
which is a cultural enterprise
that connects food and wine
with art, film, dance,
literature and philosophy.
Edición Estrella in Spain will
publish next year a compilation
of his articles.
He also does social
work on such as working
with the Spanish Cancer Society.
He has been doing a research [no
se entiende] Progress since June
of last year and two days a
week, he has been helping me
out with my own research project
on the Spanish Civil War.
And while helping me out with
my research, he has been able
to find materials
for his own research,
which he has already use to
publish a couple of articles.
So without further ado,
let me introduce
Professor Jose Berasaluce.
The lecture will be in
Spanish bu the captions will be
in English and also if you
would please turn your phones
on silent because the
lecture is going to be taped.
[ Aplauso ]
>> Muchas gracias.
Thank you very much,
Juan Manuel.
Quiero dar las gracias en primer
lugar a la Hispanic Division.
Muchas gracias, Georgette,
por todo, por nuestra ayuda.
Y le voy también las gracias
al todo el equipo del Hispanic
Division empezando
por Georgette,
Carlos Solave[phonetic] Catalina
and por su puesta a Juan
Manuel Pérez que me ha dado la
oportunidad de trabajar aquí,
de hacer mi trabaja de
colaboración con vosotros en la
investigación y también quiero
dar las gracias a Nicolas Brown
de departamento de eventos que
bueno que el facilito también el
hecho de que hoy podamos
estar aquí planteando esta
pequeña conferencia.
Y también agradecer al consulado
de España en Washington,
D.C. agradecer a José María
Ridádol [phonetic] cónsul de
España, el apoyo tan bien
recibido para esta conferencia ,
también a mi maestro,
el Catedral [no se entiende] de
filosofía de la Universidad de
Cádiz, Francisco Vásquez.
Y bueno quiere decir que es
una hora malísima para hablar
de gastronomía.
Y porque ya sabéis
para los españoles,
esta no es la hora de comer
porque comemos a partir de las
tres de la tarde, pero
esta es la hora de comer.
Yo ya llevo meses ya adaptado a
que este sea mi horario y quiero
decirles que yo vengo también
desde Cádiz que es el sur de
España que es prácticamente el
trópico, la Europa tropical, no,
donde hay una sensibilidad
especial para unir el talento,
el arte, la gastronomía,
la cultura.
Y bueno, quiero hablare del --
vamos hablar aquí de
Spanish Gastronomy y Cultural
Innovations y quiero empezar con
una frase interesante de Cicerón
que significa pensar que dice,
"Pensar es como vivir
dos veces."
To think is like living twice.
Es un gran autor que
nos invita a pensar,
a reflexionar sobre
que el pensamiento,
la reflexión representa
aumentar la vida, no?
Bien, quiero decirle
que vosotros venid --
que mi presentación aquí es como
consecuencias de que vengo de un
proyecto que se llamo,
Catas con Arte,
que es un entidad que viene
de la universidad que presta
servicios culturales a
través del conocimiento a la
gastronomía y el vino que
hacemos proyectos culturales de
todo tipo relacionando la
gastronomía en sitios tan
emblemático como esta catedral
que es la gran catedral de
las Americas.
Es la ultima de las grandes
catedrales españoles que mira
America desde la
cuidad de Cádiz.
Quiero decirles también que
nuestra hipótesis fundamental en
la spin-off Universitario Catas
con Artes es demostrar que la
cultural y el pensamiento
crítico son potenciadores de
libertad de conciencia crítica y
de ciudadanía y bueno son mas de
seis años haciendo actividades
culturales [no se entiende] y
conocimiento, las humanidades,
el pensamiento crítico,
la filosofía, el cine.
Y quiero en primer
lugar, ya que empezamos,
pues darles la bienvenido
a España.
Al partir de ahora, estamos en
España, aunque estemos en D.C.,
y he puesto esta gran foto
de la cuidad de Barcelona.
Ya sabéis, la pongo alli para
que sepáis que empezamos en
España, y os he puesto una
primera ilustración de mágico
Morra sobre de lo que
representa unos de los símbolos,
unos de los iconos de
la gastronomía que es
jamón ibérico.
Y quiere decirles lo que vamos
hacer durante esta chalar.
Pase para que sepáis
en primer lugar,
os voy a hablar de España como
potencia mundial de turismo
gastronómico, también de la
influencia de la política en la
construcción de las
ideas culinarias,
la estrecha de vinculación
entre Estados Unidos y España,
la innovación cultural,
el pensamiento crítico
como factores de cambio,
y finalmente, vamos hablar
del talento de la inteligencia
gastronómico, el capital
intelectual en el ideal de la
nueva industria culinaria
internacional.
Bueno, quiero empezar hablar del
turismo gastronómico antes de
empezar del habito del
pensamiento para decirles que la
gastronomía ya sabéis, no,
que hoy es un componente
esencial de la historia de la
tradición de la identidad
de un pueblo,
pero también se ha convertido
en un motivo muy importante para
visitar un destino.
Vais a ver diferentes
ilustraciones y fotografía de
todo tipo que vamos a
alimentar durante --
acompañar durante la charla, no.
Según la organización mundial
del turismo que es el organismo
mas solvente sobre
turismo gastronómico,
dice que este segmento tiene un
enorme potencial para estimular
las economías locales,
para promover la inclusion
y la sostenibilidad, no?
Fijase que el gran problema que
tiene el turismo gastronómico es
[no se entiende] la
estacionalidad, la formación,
se enfrenta el desafía
de la innovación,
y de todas las iniciativas
que están relacionadas con la
tecnología de la información,
y el mundo del vino.
Bueno, voy explicando
también diferente fotografías.
Pasen, pasen con tranquilidad.
Hay sitio aquí.
Os voy explicando también cada
una de las fotografías que
vais viendo.
Esta es la cuidad de Sevilla
al sur de España con el Rio
Guadalquivir y en frente,
tenemos el famosa
barrio de Triana,
unas de las cunas del cante
Flamingo internacional.
Por ese rio, entro todo el oro
y la plata de America durante
400 años.
Es importante que sepias es el
gran puerto fluían de Europa
durante la edad moderna.
Bien, la experiencia
gastronómico.
Has oído habla muchas veces
de lo que es la experiencia
gastronómico y ya sabéis
que hoy en dia el visitante,
lo que se ha venido en
llamar, el bobo Francés,
es decir la siglas
del Burgués Bohemio,
no solamente busca ver la
arquitectura de un destino,
o visitar un museo,
o de disfrutar de un
concierto de músicas y conocer,
sino conocer también la
experiencia gastronómico.
Esto es un factor para
el mundo del turismo
internacional fundamental.
Hay muchos lugares desconocidos.
Este es, como sabes, el barrio
[no se entiende] de Barcelona
pero el turismo gastronómico
tiene un gran potencial para
mejorar la gestión
de los destinos,
para promover cultural y para
contribuir a otros sectores como
la agricultura y el
mundo de la alimentación.
Bien la union estos factores,
entre gastronomía y turismo,
ofrece una plataforma ideal
para revitalizar culturales,
conservar patrimonio, empoderar
comunidades y fomentar también
el entendimiento
entre culturales.
Esto es una ilustración muy
interesante de un campaña que
valora, ya sabes, nuestra
castilla eterna y Don Quijote
que es el personaje de la
literatura española de Miguel
De Cervantes.
Bien, la semana pasada,
la organización,
Mundo del Turismo puso
un noticias muy reciente,
anuncio que España ha desbancado
a Estados Unidos como el segundo
destino internacional,
el ranking internacional
del destino turístico,
el primer país del mundo
de destino es Francés,
era Estados Unidos, España acaba
de alcanzar el segundo puesto
con 82 millones de visitas
recibidas de las cuales ocho [no
se entiende] cuatro millones de
turistas internacionales fueron
a España para conocer las
actividades gastronómicas.
Es decir que la gastronomía
fue su principal prioridad
para visitarnos.
Esto es una pequeña
localidad al sur de España,
llamada Vejer de la Frontera,
muy cerca de Gibraltar,
una de las ciudades más
interesantes que más se parase a
Moroco [phonetic] porque
estamos muy cerca a la frontera
de Moroco.
La gastronomía por lo tanto es
un elemento dinamizador de la
economía española con un
fuerte impacto en la actividad
hostelera, pero también es un
atributo diferenciador de la
marca España, eso que se ha
llamado en marca de país,
de acuerdo con un prestigio y
un reconocimiento nacional e
internacional, esta es la gastro
de la marca de España que está
promoviendo la real academia
de gastronomía Española, no.
Bien, hay un cocinero italiano
que a mi apasiona que es Massimo
Bottura que dice que la
gastronomía de la Avant-gard
debe seguir la senda de la
cultural y de las artes.
Esto es fundamental .
Y vamos entra ya -- ahora, si,
vamos a entrar en profundidad.
Esto es una pequeña creación
culinaria y gastronómica aunque
no la aparezca.
No es una obra de arte,
sino, es un plato.
Se puede comer.
Esto se puede comer.
>> ¿Qué es?
>> Bien, hay otra reflexión que
a mi me interesa hacerlo pensar.
>> ¿Qué es ese plato?
>> Pues, no se el
titulo del plato,
pero es una creación culinaria
de un restaurante de Madrid.
>> Es un postre?
>> No es salado.
Bien, hay una --
señora, si quiere,
hay sitio aquí en la sala.
Bien, hay una reflexión
de la escritora,
Luisa Echenique [phonetic] que
yo traigo aquí que dice para
ella que cultura no es una
actividad del tiempo libre,
sino lo que nos hace
libres todo el tiempo.
Esto es una reflexión
inteligente, profunda,
fundamental porque la cultural
no es una cultura de ocio.
No es algo que nos distraiga.
No es algo -- sino es
-- tiene la capacidad,
la poderosa capacidad de
hacer cambiar las cosas,
el pensamiento, la cultura,
por tanto de hacernos
mas ciudadanos,
de hacernos mas libres.
Este es el factor que para
nosotros es fundamental en
la cultura.
Por eso grandes poetas como
Federico García Lorca vinieron a
sentirse libres al
Manhattan de los años 30.
Bien, pues el despertar de la
gastronomía siempre ha estado
ligado a las grandes
revoluciones políticas.
Eso es una pequeña teoría que
os quiero plantear aquí para que
sepias que los grandes
revoluciones políticas siempre
ha sido un gran de momentos
de debates de ideas.
Y por tanto, las grandes esta
es un clásico de la revolución
industrial o esta de
la revolución francesa.
Quiero que sepáis
que la ilustración,
nos vamos atrás con mi
yo con mi estudiador,
yo hacer un pequeño marchar atas
en el tiempo, la ilustración,
el Siglo de las Luces,
y las revoluciones Burgués
atlánticas conectaron las tres
primeras ciudades del mundo
donde hubo un constitución,
en Philadelphia, en los
Estados Unidos fue la primeria,
y en Paris, y en la
cuidad de Cádiz en España.
Esas tres ciudades están
conectadas en la linea del
constitucionalismo
contemporáneo,
[no se entiende] contemporáneo
porque en esas tres ciudades
hubo el caldo de cultivo ideal
de una Burguesía capaz de
transformar la realidad
con sus ideas.
Esta es la ciudad de Cádiz,
que apropósito la traigo aquí
porque ya sabes habitante [no se
entiende] en esta pequeña
isla al sur de España.
Tenia que traerle.
Bien, la política que es eso
que ocurre en las grandes
revoluciones, se construye
siempre en torno en una mesa,
al dialogue, al encuentro,
a la discrepancia.
Y el pensamiento y las ideas
siempre tienen en la mesa --
en la compartida,
su mejor escenario.
Bueno, haga otro
enganche hacia el pasado.
La Grecia clásica tenia un
símbolo fundamental que era el
simposio que era el
banquete compartido y la --
y de hechos lo grecos creían que
solamente comiendo en común --
la institución llamada
comida en común --
se transmitáis mejor las ideas.
El simposio es el factor --
es el comienzo de una
herencia judío-Cristiano que se
materializa después también en
las grandes bacanales románticas
o simplemente en las grandes
religiones que toman siempre el
banquete como el espacio para
la transmisión de los símbolos y
para la transmisión
de las ideas.
Bien, de manera que la
alimentación juega un papel
fundamental como un código
semiótico que es muy enraizado
en la cultura popular
y, por ejemplo,
en la religión cristiana que
se da la ultima de Jesús,
como sabéis, que es un espacio,
un momento de dramatismo
y transcendencia,
siempre se ve representado por
lo grandes pintores universales
de todos los tiempos que siempre
han representado la Santa Cena
por su momento mágico y
transcendeos por Leonardo Di
Vinci, Rubén, Tintoretto,
Goya, Tiziano.
Hay muchísimos ejemplos de lo
que representa el simbolismo de
la última cena.
O por ejemplo, dando un salto
del tiempo, el restaurante,
City Tavern, en Philadelphia,
era el central social,
político y económico de la
Philadelphia de finales del
siglo 18, llamada la taberna
mas distinguida por John Adams,
uno de los primeros presidentes,
y teniendo fama como uno de
los lugares de reunión de los
miembros de Congreso
Continentales y de la Convención
-- del proceso constitucional
norteamericana.
Aquí tenéis.
Es adamas un sitio maravilloso
que puedes visitarlo.
Se puede comer perfectamente
en un ambiente recreado en
Philadelphia en el
siglo de final del 18.
Quiero también decirles una cosa
muy interesante y Presidente
Jefferson es el que le da nombre
al principal edificio de aquí
del Library of Congress.
El Presidente Jefferson fue una
persona -- fue un gran gourmet,
lo que se dice un gran
apasionado de la gastronomía y
del vino.
Ya sabéis que Jefferson fue
diplomático norteamericana en la
Francia pre-revolucionaria y
bueno pues alli Jefferson se
afranceso y va como un autentico
ilustrado por todo Francia
buscando y por el
norte de Italia,
también en España
buscando ideas,
conociendo el territorio y ya
sabéis que una de los elementos
mas interesantes de Jefferson
son todos conocimientos europeos
y que dejo escrita hasta
150 recetas de cocina que se
conservan aquí en la
Library of Congress.
Esa es una de los mas
manuales mas interesantes que
pre-trabajamos que es el de [no
se entiende] el grande maestre
de la historia de la
gastronomía con la figura de
Jefferson también.
Esta es otra de las recetas mas
famosa de Jefferson que es la de
los macaroni con la maquina.
Si, si, era un enamorado
de los macaroni el
Presidente Jefferson.
Y estas son sus letras.
Y la grafica de la propia
maquina de una carne que trae a
los Estados Unidos
importado de Paris.
Bien la relaciones económicas de
los Estados Unidos con España se
van a inicial en aquel momento.
Justamente es el momento en
que los primeros presidentes,
los primeros líderes políticos
norteamericanos y ya existía un
tráfico muy importante entre
la España de aquel momento y la
nueva Estados Unidos, la nueva
Estados Unidos de America y las
treces colonias desafiaron a la
metrópoli-inglesa con la España
de la metrópoli-española y con
particularmente con la cuidad de
[no se entiende] .
De manera que vamos a intentar
demostrar la vinculaciones que
de siempre habido en
el habito gastronomía,
cultural histórico entre
España y Estados Unidos.
Bueno, la primera relación está
en que el mismo Jefferson era un
gran consumidor de vino
franceses y de vino españoles.
De hecho, es una cosa
interesantísima que está aquí en
sala de manuales
escrito de la biblioteca.
Interesantísimo que gracias a
Juan Manuel me dio a conocer.
Y es que Jefferson empieza a
nombre todo un red de consular
-- una red de cónsules por todo
Europa con los primeros cónsules
norteamericana que en Europa,
los nombre Jefferson y entre las
muchas cartas con sus cónsul,
lo que hacía era
pedirle vino español.
Le pedio vino español a sus
cónsules y vino francés a sus
cónsules en Francia para
provisionar lo de vino,
no solamente para su
residencia en Montecello,
sino también para cuando fue
presidente de Estados Unidos.
O sea, la vinculación, el gusto
por el vino de los primeros
presidentes norteamericanos
es impresionante.
En las correspondencia
con su cónsul,
no hace nada mas que pedir.
Y era concretamente enamorado de
sherry wine que es el vino del
sur de España, tan
British también de la
Burguesía Británica.
Esta es un bodega, Sherry [no se
entiende] y esto es una de las
monografías más interesantes
de Thomas Jefferson y su
vinculación con el mundo del
viaje ilustrado y con el mundo
de los vinos, no.
Bien, y en el siglo 20, vamos
a dar un salto tremendo en
la historia.
Yo, como historiador, tengo
licencia de poder hacerlo.
Y voy a ir saltando la historia
para que veas diferente trazas,
diferentes ideas.
Quiero que sepáis que la
revueltas políticas de Mayo
1968, otro gran contexto de la
post-guerra mundial en la Europa
mas profunda, se produce un
gran catas-crismo político.
La juventud sala a la
calle, desafía el poder,
y se crea Mayo del 1968,
un momento fundamental de gran
apariencia de intelectuales,
de pensadoras en los
Francia de los años 60 y 70,
pero aquel momento político
revolucionario que no se
transforme en un revolución,
pero fue un gran contestación
de una nueva generación que no
había vivido la guerra.
En Francia, aquel momento,
Francia también alumbro un nuevo
momento gastronómico que la
aprensión de la [no
se entiende] cusine.
La [no se entiende] cusine es
un momento pragmático en la
gastronomía igual y tal como
la conocemos hoy en dia porque
Francia y Europa se desprende
de sus grandes complejos de la
guerra y comienza a
mirar hacia adelante.
Ese momento político
trae un cambio,
un movimiento gastronómico
llamada [no se entiendo] cusine
que represente un cambio
de modelo tradicional de la
cocina francesa.
Se abandonan las habilidades
artesanas y comienza a
explorarse la vías conceptuales.
Quizás unas de las grandes
imagines que representa la
Francia, el Paris, del
68, el Mayo del 68,
es la nueva llegado de la
juventud frente al poder.
Bien, Francia transforma la
realidad culinaria internacional
porque para que entendías lo
que representa la gastronomía,
Francia dice que comer ya
no es el fin, sino el medio,
el instrumente, que tiene el
chef para plantear dilemas,
para plantear debates
y reflexiones.
Y comenzamos a un nuevo
tipo de que gastronomía.
Empezamos a plantear la
aparición de restaurantes
escénicos y teatrales.
Es muy importante esta
transformación porque este es el
cambio ideológico
que produce Francia.
Bien, y otro salto,
veinte años después,
todo llegue mas tarde a España.
España es víctima de una
dictadura pero en los 80s,
se produce un cambio político
que es la transición política de
la dictadura a la democracia.
Y los años 80 traen momento de
libertad creativa en España,
un momento de transformación que
se da fundamentalmente en los
dos territorios mas
cerca de la frontera,
Cataluña y el país Basque que su
cercanía la influencia francesa
hacer clarísimo la aparición
de la libertad creativa.
Y pasamos nosotros,
los españoles,
los aromas y los gustos,
y sabores franceses a la cocina
española que representa la
emoción, el asombro, la
creatividad, y el arte efímero.
Esto es un marca de una
manzanilla buenísima que la
traído aquí porque pone abajo el
grito de viva de Pepa que es el
grito constitucional de la
constitución de Cádiz del 1812.
Fijarse el labrado,
la ilustración que hace Morra
aquí para explicar que es un
torrero con un pata de
jamón a modo de violín.
Estamos fuera [no se
entiende] así que mejor.
Bien, España en la actualidad
está a la vanguardia de la
cocina internacional.
Es muy importante que sepáis que
la gastronomía española tiene en
estos momentos una gran
capacidad de atracción y de
seducción donde no
solamente es gastronomía.
Es arte. Es moda.
Es diseño.
Es fotografía.
Es contemporaneidad.
Fijare esta fotografía que es
el escenario que tiene [no se
entiende] el restaurante que
tiene el chef Paco Roncero,
Ibiza es un restaurante que vale
1500 euros de cenar por persona,
aproximadamente unos
$1350 norteamericanos.
Es un restaurante, Emotions en
Ibiza que se hace en un hotel y
hizo una instalación.
Al fin, mira que se hace
solamente durante los meses de
verano y es el restaurante más
caro de Europa al 1500 euros
al comenzar.
Bien, la gastronomía
española, como decía,
es un universal cultural de
potencialidad y de inteligencia
de pensamiento creativo,
de cuestionar la realidad la
culinaria y de aprender a pensar
en las cocinas.
¿Estamos transformando un
momento clave porque que
representa aprender a
pensar en las cocinas?
Pues el chef, el cocinero,
no es solamente un artesano que
hace una creación culinaria,
sino que necesita leer,
necesita instruirse,
necesita generar un
pensamiento, un relato,
necesita hacer una narración
para construir ideas.
Esto es fundamental porque es
la base de nuestra teoría que
publicaremos dendro de unos
meses que ya mucha reflexión en
algún articulo que es
fundamental introducir capital
intelectual, recursos literarios
del mundo de la cultural a los
creadores culinarios si
ellos quieren realmente en la
Avant-gard gastronómica.
Por tanto, necesitamos leer.
Y además si podemos
leer en español,
mucho mejor con [no
se entiende].
Bien, hay un autentico
boom gastronómico español.
Es un proceso de cultural.
Es un autentico espacio de
oportunidad en estos momentos.
Hay una potente industria,
un enorme capacidad de
influencia en el mundo.
Estamos hablando que es un bien
cultural y estamos hablando de
valores de intercambia,
de tolerancia,
de transmisión de ideas,
según gastronómico en España,
esta simbolizado también en
personajes universales de la
cultura universal, como es el
malagueño, Pablo Luis Picasso,
que conocías como el gran
pintor de la guarda España,
la contemporánea antes
de los siglos 19 y 20.
Nuestro Picasso también
es un representante,
es un símbolo fundamental para
entender lo que les voy a decir
a continuación.
Tenéis que pensar también que
este es grave role en que están
instaladas la compañías,
las empresas gastronómicas.
El negocio gastronómico no
solo es una forma de consume,
sino el claro ejemplo
de una forma de vida.
Es decir que tras
cualquier creación culinaria,
hay una expresión cultural.
De manera que no todos
son cuenta de resultados,
ni cuadra los negocios.
Si no hay que introducir
elementos del pensamiento de la
filosofía y de la cultura
al hecho gastronómico.
Un claro ejemplo de esto es el
festival que se celebra cada año
en estos dias en la capital
de España en Madrid que es
gastro-festival alrededor de
Madrid función que es gran
congregación anual que
tiene ese festival.
Y bueno que siempre marida la
cultura con la gastronomía,
con la oferta culinaria,
con la música, con la moda,
con el mundo del vino.
Quiero que sepáis también --
vamos a introducirnos en la
filosofía de que que represente
hoy sentarse, no, sentsarse
en la mesa, compartir la mesa.
Siempre es un acto
narrativo, no?
Es decir, la mesa hace un
espacio para la creación de
metáforas porque hoy cualquier
comensal creativo que valla a
comer a un restaurante de
alta cocina o restaurante
gastronómico, o de la
guarda gastronómica,
necesita consumir
un idea, un relajo.
De manera que se producen en la
mesa numerosas significaciones
políticas y [no se entiende]
pluralidad de indentidad y
de ideas.
De manera que la alimentación
esta dendro del universo de su
dimension simbólica.
Es fundamental entender todo
esto para saber hacia dónde va
la Avant-gard gastronómica
internacional.
Un ejemplo clarísimo es esta
película europea que se llama El
Festín de Babette, una película
en los años 80 que fue Oscar una
mejor película extrajera
en el 1988,
una obra maestra que representa
los símbolos de la gastronomía,
lo que representa
sentarse en la mesa,
o se anima a que apunte la
referencia cinema autográfica.
Entonces nos tendremos
que plantear en una
pregunta fundamental.
¿Qué es la creatividad?
¿O que se necesita --
que se necesita para
hacer una creación?
Estos son las preguntas que
nos tenemos que plantear en la
ambiente de la gastronomía
y tenéis que entender que no
existe la creatividad
sin conocimiento.
Estamos aquí en el centro
internacional del conocimiento
que es Library of Congress,
la biblioteca del congreso
de los Estados Unidos.
Es fundamental entender que hay
que acercar para creer para que
produzca la guarda creadora
en el mundo de la cocina.
Hay que acercarse
al conocimiento.
Hay que profundizar
en el conocimiento.
Por tanto, el gran riesgo al
que se enfrenta la Avant-gard
gastronómica actualmente
es a lo artificial,
es decir a la vanidad,
al acceso de lujo y a una
falsa modernidad.
Este es el gran peligro, la gran
amenaza que asecha la Avant-gard
gastronómica europea
e internacional.
Aquí tenéis al Ferrán Adria
que es chef mas internacional
español que fue el chef
mas con decorado en Girona,
en la costa de Girona,
en un pequeña calita muy cerca
de la frontera francesa y ha
traspasado limites
insospechados, es uno de los --
junto con Santa [phonetic] y
Santa María que fue otro chef
[no se entiende] fue uno de
los chef mas importantes que ha
tenido España.
Bien, estamos hablando de
metáforas culturales y otra
pregunta que os planteo.
Dan de comer las
metáforas culturales?
Uno pagaría por una metáfora?
Claro se trate de que si --
la cocina es la metáfora
cultural del nivel de
civilización de un
pueblo, de acuerdo?
Pues, alguien tendría que
plantear que sentarse en la
mesa, no es una cuestión
de glotonería.
Es una cuestión también de tener
un placer intelectual porque
alguien nos está contando
algo que nos puede seducir.
El pensamiento es más
importante que el sentimiento,
que las emociones.
Las emociones pasan y los
sentimientos perduran.
Por tanto, es muy importante ser
capaces de provocar emociones en
el acto de gastronómico en la
capacidad de generar pensamiento
y de saberes intelectual, y
la provocación de emociones.
Alli está la almendra, alli está
el núcleo de lo mas importante
del [no se entiende] de la
Avant-gard gastronómica.
Por eso traemos también otra
referencia cinema autográfica
que es el discreto encanta de
la Burguesía que es una de las
película sur-realista mas
interesante que tiene la cinema
autografía español
de Luis Buñuel,
es uno de los grandes del cine
internacional que propuso una
referencia critica a la
Burguesía [no se entiende],
a la Burguesía francesa que
podía hacerse a la Burguesía
europea y que la película no
hizo otra cosa que un intento
continuo de un [no se
entiende] intentan a cenar,
y en ningún momento
pueden en toda la película.
Está llena de simbología,
de metáforas.
Y recomiendo también esta
película para que entendáis un
poco la idea que
estamos planteando.
Bien, hoy dia hay un concepto
contemporánea llamado,
élite art.
¿No? El arte de la comida --
basado en el show
gastronómico y --
pero que sepáis que
el show gastronómico,
que hoy en dias entendemos los
restaurantes de Avant-gard y el
show provocador, ha liberado
a la cocina de su clásica
marginalidad natural.
Comer y el acto gastronómico
siempre estuvo marginal como
consecuencia de que somos gene
de los culturales de grandes
guerras en los últimos años.
Por tanto la comida, siendo
el elemento de su sustancia,
de necesidad biológico
del ser humana,
de momento que la gastronomía se
convierte en la mesa en ámbito
de la sutileza del talento
de la capacidad creadora,
hay un cambio de paradigma.
Por tanto el show gastronómico
en el que hoy está la Avant-gard
gastronómico, ha liberado la
cocina de esa marginalidad
cultural en la habitaba.
Por tanto la cocina es ya hoy un
acto de creación y de talento,
siempre que no caigamos en las
extravagancias que vemos en
algunos sitios, no?
Fijamos alli, una cena de tres
grandes chef españoles del país
Basque, Aduri [phonetic] a la
izquierda, Martin Vera Sateli,
y [no se entiende] en un
especie de sala de cocina.
Y al fundo, tenéis el gran
pragmático museo Guggenheim de
Bilbao, en la area de Bilbao que
es uno de los elemento icónicos
de la arquitectura contemporánea
del norte de España.
Bien, por tanto, que
es la gastronomía?
Pues es un fenómeno junto.
Es un fenómeno complejo
y elitista.
No es glotonería
como dices antes.
No es un vulgar entrenamiento
de masas.
La gastronomía es inteligente,
es culta, es reflexible,
pero sobretodo, es un
símbolo de distinción social.
Esto es la gastronomía
hoy en dia.
Un ejemplo de distinción
social es como --
hacemos otro salto hacia atrás
para que veáis otro ejemplo
clarísimo, no?
Como Lincoln y la cocina
está muy relacionada.
¿Lo grandes presidentes
norteamericanos han sabido
utilizar el ámbito gastronómico
como un elemento de la política,
no?
Mira, en España tenemos un
elemento icónico también que se
llama el Basque Culinary
Center, en San Sebastián,
también en el norte de España,
o en Basque [no se entiende]
muy cerca de Francia.
Es la primera Facultad de
Ciencias Gastronómicas,
pensar que ha habido en los
últimos 25 años todo una
revolución de los estudios de
cocina que han aparecido por
todo el mundo, en
todas la universidades,
públicas y privadas.
Aquí hay un ejemplo muy claro
en New York, esa la escuela,
Steinhardt que son símbolos
de la educación gastronómica.
La universidad ha incorporado
los estudios de gastronomía a
sus planes a su oferta
económica.
Esta es el Basque
Culinary Center,
el edificio [no se entiende],
hecho por una universidad
privada, Basque,
con el apoyo con el
gobierno español.
Y ahora nos acercamos a
la responsabilidad de los
grandes chef.
Ya veis, ya sabéis que los
chefs son líderes de opinión en
la actualidad.
Depositar es una confianza
increíble colectiva de muchas
gente con una notoriedad
publica abrumadora, con --
yo diría que [no se
entiende] incluso,
pero los chefs están llamados a
jugar otro papel en la sociedad
porque los chefs se van
a sí mismo como grandes
Nutons [phonetic].
Perdonar la metáfora, ahora
que hablo de metáforas, no?
Grandes nutones [phonetic] de
la sociedad y necesitamos --
yo hago una reflexión critica,
una gastronomía hecho por chef
pero en una cocina mas complejo
y no tan acomplejada como se
van en muchos líderes de la
gastronomía, no?
Esta es una ilustración de
Carlos Lines que enseño para ver
ese egocentrismo absurdo y
ridículo que están muchos chefs
que nada mas se miran
a su corazón, no?
Es un ejemplo.
Bueno, que es la
inteligencia gastronómico, no?
Esto es otro pregunta
que me gustaría plantear.
Que es? ¿Se puede
hacer una teoría de la
inteligencia gastronómica?
El plato, como les decía antes,
es un objeto que
representa ideas,
pero también puede
representar incertidumbres,
no solamente belleza,
all igual que el arte.
El arte tiene una capacidad
de transformar la sociedad,
pero no solamente
representa belleza,
también representa
ideas complejas.
De manera que como
decíamos antes,
el comenzar creativo no
paga por llenar su estomago,
sino por consumir ideas
para recibir cultura.
Es decir que la creación
culinaria es un pretexto,
es un instrumento para
entender otras cosas, no?
Os traigo como ejemplo
este vino.
Fijaste este vino que viene de
España, se hace en Mallorca.
Se llama Gallinas y Focas.
Fijarse el vino.
Es un ejemplo y lo voy
a explicar rápidamente.
El vino le labora un
centro especial de empleo,
un grupo de chicos
discapacitados intelectuales que
hay en Mallorca que ellos
se encargan del todo el
proceso productivo.
Están trabajando en la
viñas bajo las órdenes de
tutores especializados.
Ellos no solamente han hecho
la producción del vino,
el cultivo del avid,
y el presando,
y el proceso de fermentación
del vino en bodega con una
autorización correcto, no, de
ingeniero agricultores, sino,
en un pequeño brainstorming
de ellos,
de un grupo discapacitados,
nombraron y titularon el vino.
Y le pusieron de manera
un poco fantastica,
Gallinas y Focas porque las
gallinas son divertidas y las
focas aplauden.
Es una pequeña reflexión de
un grupo de discapacitados
intelectuales, pero fijados como
un formidable vino es capaz de
transmitir y des-complejo
como inclusion, integración,
diferencia, discapacidad.
Y hace posible que un grupo de
discapacitados intelectuales se
sientan protagonistas de su
propio vino y lacen en el
mercado no un buen vino,
que también los es,
sino un conjunto de ideas
complejas desde el compromiso.
Fijaste, eso es un ejemplo
de lo que estamos hablando.
Bien, comerciante -- la
cultura no representa --
no solo representa belleza,
sino también toma
consciencia de los problemas.
De manera de sentarse a la
mesa es un [no se entiende]
civilizatorio lleno de
ceremonial, de sutilezas,
y por tanto un privilegio
de gente inteligente.
En las manera, el gran desafío
que enfrentamos es reconstruir
los puentes entre
saber, conocimiento,
cultura y saber que es
gastronomía y alto culinario,
no?
Otro ejemplo interesantísimo de
la Gard contemporánea española.
La Bodega Marques de Riscal,
grandes vinos, en El ciego,
en la Rioja Alavesa tiene
este pequeño pueblo de poco
habitantes con esta gran bodega
de alta contemporáneo de Frank
Gehry que es un arquitecto que
también construyo el Guggenheim
de Bilbao, pero tiene una bodega
de alta contemporáneo en medio
de un campo de viñedos en la
Rioja Alavesa espectacular
come esta.
Para fijáis un poco como en
España se está la vinculación
entre vine y arquitectura
Avant-gard contemporánea.
Bien, es fundamental vincular el
hecho gastronómico a la cultura
como dicáis os y el conocimiento
incorporar capital intelectual
al universo de la
cocina Avant-gard.
Hay en actualidad en gran debate
-- el debate es arte la cocina?
Esto una gran pregunta
que nos hacemos, no?
Es arte o es artesanía?
Hay un gran artista detrás
de cada obra culinaria o
simplemente es un artesano
que reproduce sus platos.
No me pregunten que ese
plato porque no lo se,
pero yo me lo comería
ahora mismo, no?
>> Un sushi de huevos fritos.
>> Un sushi de huevos
fritos, o, gran idea.
Bien, de manera que podemos
llegar a la conclusión de que
España es un territorio con
mucho talento gastronómico.
Chefs como Ferrán Adria en
Cataluña que a transformado la
realidad gastronómica
internacional pero que también
hay un narcisismo desquiciados
en muchos grandes chefs,
pero también la realidad
hay un gran concentración de
estrellas Michelin.
Sabes que la guía Michelin es
una guía francesa que con decora
y estables el rango, un
rango, entre una, dos,
y tres estrellas al
restaurantes de todo el mundo.
Es una de las guías que pondera,
valora objetivamente los
restaurantes del mundo.
Aquí en Estados Unidos,
no funciona también
la guía Michelin.
Me refiero que no están
seguidas pero en Europa,
es un factor de evaluación de
la calidad gastronómica, no?
Pero fijar como ese gran chef,
que es Ferrán Adria es capaz
de hacer grandes proyectos
internacionales con
el grupo Disney.
Le voy a traer otro ejemplo
hasta dónde puede llegar la
gastronomía española.
La NASA que ya sabias
es el organo --
es la agencia norteamericana
del espacio.
Lleva 50 año innovando, celebro
el pasado mes de noviembre en
Houston una cumbre llamada,
Cross Industry Innovation
Summit,
en la que fue invitado
un chef español,
junto a grande científicos
y grandes astronautas,
también un chef español, no para
decir lo que tengan que comer
los astronautas, no, sino como
ejemplo de innovación multi
sensorial en el ámbito
gastronómico.
Aquí lo tenéis en Houston,
hace un mes y media,
un chef español en el panel
de expertos de la innovación
internacional planteando
como desde la gastronomía,
se puede hacer innovación,
se puede innovar.
Bien, hay otro personaje
interesantísimo y complejo que
es el .pintor Salvador
Dalí, no se si lo conocéis.
Es un pintor muy representativo
de la Avant-gard española,
un gran excéntrico, nadie puede
negar su maestría artística pero
hay que también reconocerle que
ha sido el máximo exponente del
movimiento surrealista en la
plastica y era un gran enamorado
de la gastronomía, muy vinculado
a las ideas culinarias en estas
extravagancias surrealistas
que hacía,
estás grandes mesas montajes,
uniendo el pavo real,
la grandes creaciones
astronómicas de las que el era
estaba obsesionado
con la astronomía.
Grandes obras plásticas
estaban muy influenciadas por
lo culinaria.
Bien, pues a Dalí le gustaba
recurrir a objetos astronómicos
para expresarse.
Hay una frase fantastica
que dice, Y nosotros,
los surrealistas, somos como una
comida de buena calidad o como
el [no se entiende], no,
que la belleza se da
comestible o no se da.
Bueno, sabes que Dalí tuvo una
influencia muy interesante en la
clase creadora norteamericana
de [no se entiende] reconoció el
rango mundial.
Concretamente, el y Walt
Disney tuvieron un relación muy
compleja, muy interesante
de amistad y de influencia.
Hicieron incluso un
corto que no se pudo --
un corto metraje que no se pudo
llegar a realizar pero que ha
sido reestrenado
60 años después.
Y la relación de Dalí, que es un
gran artista contemporáneo con
Walt Disney, es muy importante.
Es el universo creativo
de Disney.
Por tanto, podemos concluir
entre Picasso, entre Dalí,
entre los chefs de la actualidad
que los intelectuales,
el pensamiento crítico, los
artistas, los filósofos hoy,
aunque parezcan que no porque
el capitalismo nos impide decir
esto, pero hoy puedo decirlo
yo aquí en la biblioteca del
Congreso, la filosofía tiene,
y el pensamiento crítico,
y los intelectuales tienen
la enorme responsabilidad de
imaginar un mundo mejor y
de cambiar la realidad con
sus ideas.
Este es el gran papel
de los intelectuales.
Este señor, Franklin,
fue un gran intelectual,
fruto de este gran
hombre de renacimiento,
nacido en Philadelphia, cambio
la realidad política de un país.
La gastronomía española también
conocéis la palabra "TAPA."
Las TAPAs española
son un espacio.
Las TAPAS son un símbolo.
Las TAPAs no es otra cosa que
un invento para comer más con
porciones más pequeñas.
Es una cosa rápida, agradable
que se aleja de la clásica
jerarquía francesa y lo que
trate de demuestra con la TAPA
es que con pequeño bocados,
puedo comer mas cosas y
de una manera mas ligera.
Pues bien, la TAPA ha demostrado
una gran capacidad de innovación
porque de alguna manera las
TAPAs en la cocina miniatura son
bocados de libertad.
Son el símbolo de la libertad
creadora de una cultura España,
española, que exporta libertad
en la mesa en el mundo.
Eso es la TAPA de alguna
manera porque rope además,
come decías antes la
clásico jerarquía del ritual
gastronómico que imponía
francés como [no se entiende].
Aprovecho para decirles que el
16 de junio es el dia mundial de
la TAPA y hay pocos sitios [no
se entiende] se coman TAPA,
así que podéis hacer las
TAPAS en casa también.
España también exporta al mundo
este modelo de food markets que
se están viendo en todas
las ciudades del mundo.
Hay food markets originales.
Otros son más de plástico.
Otro son inversiones,
pero España también es capaz de
exportar como este gran mercado
de San Miguel junto a la
plaza mayor de Madrid.
Ese concepto de foco
Hispano, Latino,
espacio de intercambio donde
siempre hay vida, hay un autor,
llamado Fernando Quinones que
decía que siempre cuando conocía
una ciudad, visitaba dos cosas,
los cementerios y los mercados
porque dice que es la forma de
entender la cuidad.
Yo incorporo también la
biblioteca como tercer como
tercer elemento.
Siempre hay que conocer las
bibliotecas de cada cuidad.
Bien, hay otro ejemplo
importante.
Vamos a bajar al
terreno, bajamos el balón.
En el 88 en aquí en
Washington, D.C.,
unos de los íconos de
la gastronomía española,
La Taberna Alabardero
del Padre Luis Lezema,
abre su restaurante a muy
pocos metros de la Casa Blanca.
Es uno de los símbolos de
la gastronomía española.
A partir de alli,
hace mas de 30 años --
bueno justamente
30 años ahora --
han abierto cientos de
restaurantes españoles por todos
los Estados Unidos, pero
este hombre fue pionero,
el Padre Luis Lezema.
Este es el restaurante.
Quiero decir por tanto que
el español, como idioma,
que es el idioma de en que me
estoy hablando con vosotros,
la cultura y sobretodo la
gastronomía tiene un papel
fundamental que re-indicar, no,
frente a la cultura
norteamericana.
Es fundamental el crecimiento
de el español, de la cultura,
y también apropiado la
gastronomía española tiene un
desafió fundamental en su
relación de lo que representa la
cultura Hispana, España, Hispana
America frente a su relación con
Estados Unidos.
Bueno, hasta donde
vamos a llegar?
Hasta donde vamos a
llegar con la Avant-gard?
Pues se puede llegar hasta un
acontecimiento fundamental.
No se si conocéis en Alemania en
la ciudad de Casal que esta la
gran feria, documenta la gran
feria internacional de arte
contemporánea, es la feria
de referencia internacional
mas importante.
Pues, hasta ese punto
se puede llegar,
hasta el punto en que la
gastronomía española y su
experiencia culinaria llega haz
que inviten a un chef como un
gran creador de la
contemporaneidad a la gran
feria, Casal.
De manera que nos podríamos
hacer otra pregunta.
Quien no pagaría por un
producto de Avant-gard?
Es un producto de Avant-gard
una creación gastronómica?
Esa es la gran feria en Casal
que nos animo a ir algún año.
De manera que para concluir
esta pequeña charla,
quiero decir os varios cosas.
Primero que la gastronomía es
algo con mucho futuro y que el
futuro es cosa de todos.
Este no soy yo.
Es el foro, pero es un ejemplo
de futuro de mirada hacia
adelante y termino con una frase
de mi querido Manuel Vásquez
Montalbán que nos va ayudar
entender la idea sustancial de
lo que hemos hablado aquí.
Comer o no comer puede ser
una cuestión de dinero,
pero comer bien o comer mal
es una cuestión de cultura.
Muchas gracias y
hasta la próxima.
[ Aplauso ]
>> Do we have time
for a few questions.
Do you have one?
>> Por que no nos explicas un
poquito mas sobre que son las
Catas con Arte?
>> Bueno, las Catas con Artes es
la iniciativa que la provengo y
que no es otro cosa que intentar
plantearle problemas a la gente,
es decir, a través
de la gastronomía.
Es un grupo de investigación
de la filosofía que nos plantea
dilemas e ideas complejas que
nosotros llevamos a la mesa,
tema [no se entiende] es todo
entre 50 desconocidos y lo
hacemos en hoteles.
De manera que lo que
intentamos demostrar,
como les decías al principio,
voy a poner un ejemplo.
Pues la Catas con Arte es la
realización de muchas cenas [no
se entiende] donde planteamos
una cena entre 50 desconocidos
con un idea que prevalece
en la cena.
Como por ejemplo, le voy a
dar un ejemplo complicado,
el escepticismo o por ejemplo
otro complejo que es si es mas
habitual y que nos gusto a
todos que es la traición.
La traición es un elemento
con sustancia a la condición.
Quien no se ha sentido
traicionado alguna vez?
Bueno a ese cena en la que
hablamos de traición y de
deshonra, la llamamos
"puñalada trapera."
Ya sabéis lo que es un
puñalada trapera, no?
Un [no se entiende]
de la traición.
Todo el mundo convive
con la traición.
Bueno, encontramos un profesor,
siempre un especialista en
la universidad española,
que lleva años trabajando,
investigando sobre lo que
representa la traición,
y ese señor comparte
mesa con 50 desconocidos.
El chef que crea las creaciones
gastronómica las hace a base de
la idea de la traición, donde
se incorpora música y director,
una [no se entiende] teatral
y donde se plantea un debate,
una entre iguales, no?
Esto que lo hacemos por
muchos lugares de España,
muchos hoteles con
Universidad de Cádiz,
de Sevilla y de Madrid,
la confluencia de Madrid pues
tiene un enorme transcendencia
porque estamos planteando que
el hecho gastronómico puede ser
abordado desde lo intelectual y
desde el conocimiento y con unas
estigmáticas provocadoras y
sobretodo incomodas siempre, no?
Entonces alli encontramos una
[no se entiende] para que nos
hable de lo que representa la
noche y los vampiros o por el
ejemplo, la mentira, el arte
de mentir es una de nuestras
grandes catas porque la mentira
es innecesario para la vida
del hombre.
Pues un especialista de mentiras
en la Universidad de Sevilla que
representa la mentira, la
literatura en la vida diaria,
en la condición humana.
Bueno, incorporamos a la
profesional, a la experta,
es decir, a la profesora,
al conocimiento y lo
incorporamos con música,
creaciones gastronómica
que esta relacionadas --
>> Que es no fake.
>> No son fake.
No son fake.
Es de verdad.
[No se entiendo] Que bueno
nosotros lo que intentamos es
demonstrar que el pensamiento
y la filosofía tiene una enorme
capacidad de transformar
la realidad a través de la
gastronomía y los vinos.
Entonces nosotros,
como filósofos en el
ámbito del pensamiento,
lo que nos interesa es eso,
transmitir conocimiento,
ideas complejas de la filosofía
a través de la gastronomía.
Es decir antes hacíamos
conferencias aburridísimas y
ahora la hacemos comiendo
y bebiendo con 50 personas,
y además con música, con teatro,
y con una bodega de vinos.
El mundo del vino es un
mundo lleno de complexidad,
se sutileza y donde hay un
enorme capacidad de inventar
cosas nuevas.
Eso es Catas con Arte.
Ese el proyecto que me
ha traído a mi aquí.
Y además es un proyecto que
haya recibido bueno mucha
reconocimiento en España,
pero no vamos hacer Catas
con Arte en Estados Unidos.
De momento es algo
que mi amigo, Alberto,
me propongo que haga otra cosa,
pero que la idea es traer
un poco la reflexión que ha
suscitado todo en España
y traerlo aquí en los
Estados Unidos.
[No se entiende]
>> Parase que la clave está en
la creación de fuentes entre lo
tangible y no tangible.
Lo tangible siendo el mundo del
saber para poder llegar al mundo
del saber.
Estados Unidos y lo
Hispano, en general,
lo Hispanounidenses que está
siendo negado en Estados Unidos
desde la política es una
aprobación anti-gastronómica.
Y como vez o visualizas la
posibilidad de creer ese puente
para generar lo Hispanounidenses
dendro del
mundo Anglo-Estadounidenses?
Existe o vez una conexión entre
ese mundo del sabor Hispano y la
realidad Anglo-Estadounidenses
mas allá de montar un [no se
entiende] de TAPAS?
>> Yo creo que la
gastronomía, la cultura,
pero la gastronomía es
un instrumento ideal para
acercar posturas.
Es decir tú haz planteado
la político, en esta caso,
como un conflicto,
como un problema,
como un choque entre lo
norteamericano y lo Hispano
porque hay ese conflicto
político en Estados Unidos en
este momento, pero la
gastronomía tiene la enorme
capacidad de sentar a la
mesa y hacer entender a
los discrepantes.
Entonces la gastronomía
-- con la gastronomía,
sentándose en la mesa, la
gente se entiende mejor,
incluso con el vino,
todavía más.
Me quiero referir que la enorme
trascendencia que tiene el
universo simbólico de la
gastronomía puede hacer llegar a
entender la intolerancia a la
diferencia que existe en ese
convivencia que parase ahora
imposible desde la política,
pero que se dará porque el mundo
Hispana y la cultura Hispana va
a crecer en los próximos
30 años en este país,
y del entendimiento que puede
produce espacio de convergencia
como es la cocina
y la gastronomía,
se puede construir
realidades sociales diferentes.
De manera de que alguien debería
de hacer un plan estratégico
gubernamental de la gastronomía
y la lengua española en los
Estados Unidos para que se
entiendan dos realidades que no
viven de espalda, sino que
están confinadas al entenderse.
Entonces alguien debería
de planea esto para que la
convivencia de esta
sociedad multi-versatilidad y
multicultural, que es
los Estados Unidos,
entienda de una manera tranquila
y natural que lo Hispano es
también hispanounidenses como
va [no se entiende] ese nombre.
>> José, existen tendencias de
mayormente participación de las
mujeres como chef como lideras
[no se entiende] en el España o
en el mundo?
>> Catalina, me encanta
la pregunta,
pero tienes que entender que
hay una enorme misoginia --
una enorme misoginia -- en
el mundo de la gastronomía.
Es una cosa -- hay que
-- había que plantear --
yo se le encargo al Departamento
de ONU Mujeres debería de
entender que la gastronomía
debe ser igualitaria.
Y hay un problema y es que en
las cocinas del mundo cocinan
mujeres, pero solamente los
chefs con reputación son hombre.
Esto es una autentica
barbaridad.
Alguien debería de
montar un plan igualdad,
de trans-versatilidad,
de entendimiento para que la
mujer también se visualize en el
ámbito de la Avant-gard
creadora.
>> Tiene un problema
en el mundo.
>> Es un problema en
el mundo efectivamente.
Por ejemplo, la cocina Peruano
que hay hecho un gran esfuerzo
por conquistar el mundo a
través de su plan gastronómico,
bueno también solamente se ven
chef barones cuando la capacidad
de creadora es igualmente en
la mujer que en el hombre.
Y es un grave problema atajar.
La pregunta es fantastica.
Georgette.
>> [No se entiende]
José Andrés --
>> Si.
>> -- también da mucha cultura
española por veinte años.
>> Efectivamente.
José Andrés también es uno
de los chefs españoles más
importante que está en los
Estados Unidos que además tiene
una cosa muy interesante que
es el compromiso por los demás.
Un señor que después del huracán
que ha azotado recientemente en
Puerto Rico, se acercado
durante un mes,
ha dejado sus negocios y se ha
acercado a dar de comer a las
víctimas del huracán
durante el mes.
Los chefs tienen la enorme
responsabilidad de comprometerse
con los de más, de hacer cosas
por los demás porque tienen un
altísimo nivel de reputación
y tienen que comprometerse
públicamente con los demás.
No puede ser que total el
capital que están recibiendo de
la sociedad no se la devuelvan
con compromisos hacia lo demás.
José Andrés es un ejemplo
maravilloso de compromiso por
los demás y de gastronomía,
de cómo el liderazgo que
representa la gastronomía puede
hacer visualizar a la
sociedad a gente comprometida.
>> Muchas gracias.
>> Muchísimas gracias.
[ Aplauso ]
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.